(audience cheering)
- I'm so excited you're here.
- I'm so excited that I'm here.
- Are you?
- I have not been on a
talk show in a minute.
- Really?
- I'm sleep-deprived,
and this is-
- Huh, this is gonna be fun.
- So much joy.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
That was joyful.
You're joyful.
- Hi
- I love speaking to people
when they're tired (chuckles).
- Yeah, it's-
- Because then, you just talk.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's a little dippy.
- It's funny, yeah.
That's me too. I'm the same way.
Well, we were speaking of regional foods
'cause we're doing this
whole "Final Fork" thing
on our show.
So, I hear you have an issue
with the coffee in Canada.
What's up?
- This got a lot of people
upset when I posted about it.
- A lot of people in Canada?
- Yes.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
In Canada
where I work quite often,
I really like working there.
They have some-
- I love Canada.
- Of the best crews in
all of show business.
However, their cold brew is lacking.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
I'm a cold brew aficionado,
I need it strong, rocket fuel.
And they'll give you like
two choices in a thing,
and you gotta search far and wide.
And here, we have like cold brew-
- [Kelly] Everywhere.
- Yeah, everywhere.
- Yeah.
- Well, I know that you've
talked about this a billion times
but my family will actually
kill me if I don't bring it up.
- Okay.
- So, you're welcome.
I know people have to always ask you
about Christmas vacation,
but like, I love this movie.
- How can you get mad at that?
- And I know it's...
Well, I'm just saying, it's been a minute,
so maybe we shouldn't.
It's one of my
(audience cheering)
favorite.
I have never...
Like I spend Christmas with you,
everyone does, that's an incredible thing.
To make so many movie shows, music,
but to have this thing that's
like so culturally just
in our brains and in our...
Every year, different generations.
- No, no, no.
- Very few people are part
of something like that.
- That's right.
- Did you know it was gonna be like that?
- No, I did not.
I did-
- Okay.
- An interview yesterday...
You know, I'm midlife so I'm
going through many important
emotional transitional things.
Seizing beautiful, learning how
to appreciate what you have.
And so I get really... (laughs)
I'm gonna cry.
- Oh, you get emotional by it?
- No, no.
Christmas vacation, it's so touching.
- Yeah.
- That every year,
as a little...
I was just 15.
Sorry, I didn't mean to cry.
- That's so...
No, look. I cry so much on this show.
(audience cheering)
- No, no.
- They have it here for me.
- It's an incredible thing though,
to be a part of people's lives
- All people-
- every Christmas,
- They're like,
(Kelly speaks faintly)
- "You're a part of my family."
People who've lost their
parents or whatever,
and what it meant to them.
It's a tradition.
- You're a part of those memories.
- And so what I'm saying is, no,
you can never imagine
that is ever gonna happen
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In a film you do.
I was just 15 years old.
- That's so crazy young.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Chevy Chase
is really supportive.
Johnny Galecki who, of course, who went on
to do "Big Bang Theory"
and many other things.
And we were just the new
Griswold kids at that time.
- It was amazing.
Anyway, I had to bring it up-
- Every year.
- Or my family would kill me.
(audience cheering)
So, this show you're
on now is "Yellowjackets."
So, for those who don't
know about the show,
tell them kind of what it's about.
- I'm the worst pitch
person, but we're gonna try.
- I can't wait.
- Okay.
(Juliette and Kelly laughs)
- Yeah.
- No, no.
Okay, wait.
A group of teens in the '90s,
they're on a little soccer team.
Their plane crashes, and
it's all these things they do
to survive in the wilderness.
We-
- That we don't know.
- That we don't know what they do.
- Yeah.
- Yet.
- You're finding out slowly.
- We're gonna find out slowly,
and then there's the
older versions of them
which is myself, Melanie Lynskey-
- Christina Ricci.
Tawny Cypress.
And two new additions,
(audience cheering)
Lauren Ambrose and Simone Kessell.
- Yeah.
- And we are the older
version with all the trauma
and the secrets we keep, and
a lot of us act very strange.
- Yeah, you do.
- They do strange things.
I feel like my character's the
most sane 'cause her pain is
just kind of obvious.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
The other girls like kill things.
- I love that you think
yours is sane.
(audience laughs)
(laughs) I love...
- She's volatile-
- So, she...
(Kelly laughs)
- Sad.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
All the fun things to put into one thing.
So your dad,
you said your dad raised you
to be a quitter (laughs).
- Oh, this is my favorite line.
(Kelly laughs)
- Why?
(audience exclaims)
- Oh my God. Adorable.
- Oh my God.
Am I gonna cry again?
I'm not even-
- Here.
Look, I'm here for you.
- I'm not even premenstrual.
(audience laughs)
- I'm not even... (laughs)
- What the (beep) is happening?
(Kelly clapping)
(Kelly laughing)
Oh my God, and you blew it up.
(audience cheering)
Oh my god (laughs).
(Kelly laughs)
- I love you.
Wait, so what...
Oh my God. You're fine.
I'm about to hug you-
- Why-
- But that might make
it worse.
- No, no.
And I'm crying over joyful things.
- Yeah, no it's beautiful.
I love this picture too.
But why do you think he
raised you to be a quitter?
(Kelly and Juliette laughs)
(audience laughs)
Just curious.
- Because he was a pushover.
I went to gymnastics and
then the girls were mean.
They're like, "Hey, a flea
is jumping out of your hair."
I was eight.
I was like, "Ooh,"
and I'm like, "What?"
You know, they're just making (beep) up
to be evil and mean.
- Yeah (laughs).
- So he would just what, let you-
- So, the different things,
if I got pissed off or shut down,
he'd be like, "So, don't go.
You don't have to go back."
So that was that.
But however, like karate,
I would like to be a black belt right now.
I never made it past brown
(Kelly laughs)
'cause I don't know,
maybe I was tired one day.
(audience laughs)
But I
coulda used the discipline.
- He didn't pushed you?
Yeah.
- I like karate discipline
and then singing-
- I need you
to tell my children this.
- Teachers.
Yeah.
- Because I make my children
finish things out.
- Really?
- And I get crap for it.
And I'm like, "You don't
have to do it next time
but you're definitely gonna
finish what mama paid for.
'Cause mama grew up
- Yes.
- In a duplex in an apartment
and I did not have a lot of money."
And even though you have money,
you still don't like to waste it.
And it's like you gotta teach them,
they have to follow through.
- Well, that's my sister
and it's the smarter move.
If I had kids...
I'm the Lucille Ball of aunts,
I like to say,
(audience laughs)
like the auntie.
I know people associate me with cool,
but I'm really like (laughs),
(Kelly laughs)
"Hey, guys."
And I'm really like
(audience laughs)
prudent with them.
- Yeah.
- But what I wanted to say, I
think that's the correct way.
Encourage someone to
finish through the hardship
of some things.
But I did have a ballet
teacher that when I had...
It's weird 'cause it did
good and bad things for me.
I had a ballet teacher,
I had ripped tights,
we didn't have much money.
I was living with my mom and I was like,
"Oh, maybe she won't notice."
And I just had leg warmers, I
was like seven, and a leotard.
And I show up, it's the first thing.
She goes, "Now, see? This is
what I've been telling you
about presentation."
(Kelly exclaims)
"Look at Juliette."
And I'm like, I'm seven,
and noticing I've-
- Oh, that's not cool.
- It wasn't cool, and I never went back.
That's my big move.
I was like, "I'm done with you."
(audience laughs)
And that served me well
in certain things.
- Yeah, I agree with that
because we had a similar moment happen.
I had the shoes that you got
from a store that cost like...
You know, they were like
6.99 for tennis shoes,
and that's where we shopped.
- Casual (speaks faintly).
- Yeah.
And a great store, by the way,
for people that don't have a lot of money.
And so anyways, so I played basketball
and I made marks on the floor, I guess.
And I didn't know my
shoes were making marks
but the coach put us all
aside and he was like,
"Look at your shoes.
Whose shoes are making all
these marks on the floor?"
And I didn't even realize,
and then I kept hearing all the girls go,
"Those are cheap shoes, only
cheap shoes make those marks."
(audience exclaims)
And I had never...
I walked out of the gym and I was like...
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
I was like, "Don't make a move."
I was like, "Whose shoes did that?"
(Juliette laughs)
- I was like
(audience laughs)
so tacky.
I was mortified, and it did,
and then I had to go back-
- [Juliette] Oh, God.
- In the same shoes.
- What?
- Because my mom couldn't
afford anything else.
We didn't have money.
And I had to go back in the same shoes
because my mom was like,
"You're finishing it out."
And I'm glad she made me finish it out.
But those moments, teachers should know,
people should know better.
- Yeah, they-
- To point that out
'cause some people can't
afford the other option.
- That is the biggest thing.
I remember flip-flopping my pants
I'll wear these and then
the same ones on Wednesday,
maybe they won't notice,
like all that stuff.
But that's so sad that
teacher had no idea,
the one little fear like,
"Ah, I have cheap shoes."
No one will know.
I'll play good, I'll play strong.
And it's like,
"Look at me. It's cheap
shoes (beep) our floor-
- What made it worse-
- With your (beep)."
- You can't. We'll bleep it out though.
- Yeah, yeah. You're not...
- But what made it worse-
- What?
- Was I actually
wasn't good either.
- Oh, God.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was good at volleyball
but not basketball.
- It's okay.
Okay.
- So it was like... (laughs)
- I was impressed this-
- What made it worse was like,
- Whole time.
- "Why am I here?"
(Juliette and Kelly laughs)
Anyway, it builds character.